AND FEELING ONE ANOTHER OUT CAR.
KOSKINEN, A SAVE.
[ WhistleAMES COMING
IN.
WORKED IT AROUND.
KOSKINEN WILL FALL ON IT. ]
[ Applause ]
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Jack: HE MAKES NO MISTAKE,
GOING UPSTAIRS
OUTSIDE, HE JUST SHOOTS T T MAN.
SHARP.
BUT THERE WAS NONE FORTHCOMING.
A SHOT.
SAVE,ENTZEL HE EXTENDS THE
LONGEST ACTIVE POINT STREAKFACEL
OPENING UP FOR THAT ONE-TIMER,
AND HE Cheering and Applause ]
>> Jack: EDMONTON REGAINS THE
LEAD, 2-1! THE DEFENSIVE
ZONE TO MAKE A
SPRAWLING SAVE MADE THAT TIME BY
JARRY WHO HAS GOT IT. HYMAN
2-ALL.
>> Louie: IT IS THE SEC FOUND
HIS NICHE HERE ON THE TOP LINE
AND IT INTO NUGENT-HOPKINS AND
HYMAN FOR THE HAT TRICK! LANDS A
GREAT SAVE BY JARRY TO DENY
HYMAN OF HIS FIRST-EVEKE-CHECKED
NOW YAMAMOTO, JUMPING UP INTO
THE SLOT BUT DENIE CORNER GRASST
OF PLAY AND REALLY NOBODY THIS ,
OUTSHOT SO FAR THROUGH TWO
PERIODS AND KOSKINEN GIVING
KAILER YAMAMOTO!
GIVES EDMONTON THE LEAD, 3-2.
[ Horn ]
AND THAT WAS BY
AND BOUCHARD, A TAP-IN ANDLd Ap]
[ Horn ]
[ Cheering and Applause ]NK,
PARTNER?
>> Louie: I THINK THAT IT IS
RODRIGUES, IMPRESSING ME WITH
HIS SPEED THROUGHOUT THIS GAME,
TAKES